what a better way to kick things off
than with a pop quiz
this isn't a regular pop quiz it's a
cool pop quiz and here's how it works
during our final segment we're gonna
choose one vff to answer three questions
about today's show
one question correct a hundred bucks
two questions correct two hundred bucks
all three one
thousand dollars i know it's so fun
but this is a special game show week
edition treat
so we'll ask a bonus question worth
four thousand dollars so
it's a total of five thousand dollars at
stake oh my gosh vfs look excited
okay i'm so excited you guys look really
happy about this and so am i
so stick around to play along at the end
of the show
and pay attention throughout the show
because you're gonna need to answer
clues
from the show itself vff heather and
ashley from
wyoming bye
okay i'm really excited um okay here we
go if you can answer
uh correctly three questions about
today's show you win a thousand dollars
and if you answer the fourth question
correctly
you win a total of five thousand dollars
are you ready
yes i hope so well you look like winners
to me
first question which actor did drew talk
to at the beginning of today's show
dakota johnson yeah
hi okay second question what did i
put on my head during the design by drew
segment
the towels nice and tight to the head
you see what i'm saying okay third
question
what does anne hathaway prefer to be
called
annie it is b anne hathaway
anne hathaway wants to be called annie
from now on oh my god i'm getting
lightheaded oh that's a thousand dollars
okay here's a bonus question for extra
credit
all right if you get this correct you'll
take home a total of five
thousand dollars the yummy brothers
baked special cookies for me
what movie did the cookies honor you
juice eat cookie which is means
extra tasty eating
[Applause]
i'm not kidding i'm like
[Applause]
oh my god you're so good you guys took
enough
[Laughter]
a vacation trip next month and this will
help so much oh my gosh
thank you so much for being here with us
today and congratulations by the way
four out of four
well done honey well done
all right everybody we hope to see you
again tomorrow
we love you heather and ashley we'll see
you soon
thank you so much have a great day
[Music]
you